- Man, it's 2001, and there is so much
tension over Afghanistan right now.
George Bush is threatening to invade,
but as leftists, we really don't want war.
So, he should really work on deescalation.
Afghanistan, we understand you have a
radicalism problem, and this really scares
the US fresh after 9/11. So, what
you should do right now, Afghanistan,
is to keep talking to the US. Keep
George Bush talking. Listen to him.
Give diplomacy a chance.
Don't look threatening,
don't say anything anti-American.
Give peace a chance, Afghanistan.
Even as US troops are massing on your
border, clearly preparing to attack,
don't stop trying to solve
the conflict diplomatically.
You have to keep trying, Afghanistan.
What's that? The US started this, not us?
Oh, well... (stammering)
we didn't catch that, Afghanistan.
We can barely hear you. What's that?
The US launched the invasion?
Okay, first off, it's a
"special military operation",
that only happened because you
haven't extradited Osama bin Laden.
I mean, the US bombarding your cities,
and murdering your people
really is an understandable reaction.
Besides, do you have any proof that
the US committed these atrocities?
It's more than likely that all the murder
and destruction was done by Afghanis to try
and frame the US, riding the wave of this
bizarre Americophobic global sentiment.
Anyway, as we said, we're interested in peace
above all, so now, just let the US finish the job
quickly, don't resist, and let them plant you
firmly in the US sphere of influence,
where you belong. The sooner you give up,
Afghanistan, the sooner the war will be over,
thus the sooner will
there be peace in our time.
Because, apparently,
this is how leftism works.